nos dicen que x es igual a 2 x 1 / x + 3
y con base en esto lo que quiero
encontrar y averiguar es cuál es la
función inversa de g la función inversa
de g y bueno te invito a que pause el
vídeo y veas a cuánto equivale esta
expresión
ok suponiendo que lo intentaste y sólo
con un pequeño recordatorio vamos a
hablar de las funciones inversas si por
ejemplo aquí me tomó el dominio déjame
ponerlo así éste será mi dominio que es
el conjunto de todas las posibles
entradas que podemos poner en la función
g y por acá me tomo también mi rango
déjame ponerlo por acá es de aquí es mi
rango es decir el conjunto de todas las
posibles salidas de mi función que y ya
que tenemos esto ahora fijémonos en una
entrada dada lo voy a poner con su
respectivo color
imagínate que por aquí me tomo una
entrada en el dominio ya esta entrada le
aplicó la función que la voy a poner con
su respectivo color me voy a tomar aquí
a la función g y ésta me manda a un
valor en el rango lo voy a poner con su
respectivo color este de aquí es un
miembro del rango así que si éste por
aquí se llamaba x
su correspondiente miembro en el rango
va a ser gtx
d
ok entonces esto es lo que hace la
función que ahora la función inversa va
en sentido contrario empieza con un
miembro del rango en este caso voy a
tomar a ese mismo y vas a regresar a un
miembro del dominio esto es lo que hace
la función inversa de g
ahora bien hay un par de formas de ver
esto si dijéramos por ejemplo que gtx es
lo mismo que dejar de ponerle nombre
aquí james es igual a fede x entonces
este de aquí es james déjame ponerles y
este de aquí es bien entonces dada una
equis podemos decir que james o gdx es
lo mismo que dos veces x menos 1 todo
eso dividido entre x + 3 esto lo que nos
da es una gtx asociada a esa equis o una
bien asociada a esa equis pero qué pasa
si nos dan una y una
gx como podemos obtener a x a partir del
eje x bueno pues simplemente para eso
nos sirve la función inversa y para
obtenerla lo que vamos a hacer es
resolver para x vamos a despejar a equis
entonces vamos a hacerlo y para esto lo
que voy a hacer es poner aquí que james
bien es igual a esta parte de aquí a dos
x menos 1 esto entre x + 3 y bueno
queremos resolver para x para que
sepamos para cualquiera bien cuál es la
x correspondiente a ese valor asociado
allí entonces cómo hacemos esto bueno
qué te parece si multiplicamos ambos
lados de esta ecuación por x + 3
voy a multiplicar de este lado por x 3
exacto y de este lado también voy a
multiplicar por x + 3 de tal manera que
es
y este se van a cancelar y entonces que
me queda me va a quedar bien que
multiplica que multiplica a x + 3 esto
va a ser igual a 2 x menos 12 x menos 1
y luego veamos que podemos hacer ahora
bueno pues podemos distribuir la jem la
vamos a multiplicar por equis y también
la vamos a multiplicar por 3 así que voy
a cambiar de color y me va a quedar lo
siguiente
x que multiplica james por x es lo mismo
que x + 3 veces y esto es lo mismo que
2x menos 1 y recuerda estamos intentando
resolver para x entonces lo que podemos
hacer es poner todos los términos con x
de un lado de la ecuación y luego todos
los términos que no involucran a x del
otro lado de la ecuación entonces vamos
a poner todos los términos que tienen
que ver con x del lado izquierdo de la
ecuación y los que no tienen que ver con
x del lado derecho entonces veamos este
equipo no tiene involucrado a x entonces
lo voy a pasar del otro lado y para eso
lo voy a restar menos 3 james y aquí
también voy a poner menos 3 bien muy
bien
y ahora estés involucra x pero este que
también involucra x yo quiero tener del
lado izquierdo así que para eso voy a
restar 2x y voy a hacer lo mismo de este
lado voy a restar 2 x
y así que me va a quedar bueno del lado
izquierdo me va a quedar x james menos 2
x eso es exactamente lo mismo que x que
multiplica a menos 2 lo único que estoy
haciendo es factor izando la x porque la
tenemos como un factor común estos dos
se van y bueno de este lado estos dos se
van y me quedan que esto es lo mismo que
menos uno menos tres veces bien y ahora
como queremos x que te parece si
dividimos todo entre menos 2 todo / 10 -
2 de tal manera que este con este se va
a cancelar y ahora sí voy a obtener que
x x es igual a menos uno menos 3 james
está dividido entre menos 2 ahora una
forma de verlo es decir que esta función
que tengo aquí es lo mismo que la
función inversa que depende
de james porque si nosotros metemos una
ya que ir un ayer que está en el rango
es un elemento del rango y la ponemos en
esta definición de la función entonces
te puedo dar una correspondiente x te
voy a dar una correspondiente x que vive
en el dominio ahora nosotros no nos
preguntamos por qué inversa de james lo
que queríamos era g inversa de x
recuerdas
ahora bien algo muy importante es que
estas variables que metemos adentro de
nuestra función las elegimos de una
manera arbitraria simplemente dicen voy
a llamar a mi entrada
james y entonces la función que es lo
que voy a obtener de salida es menos uno
menos tres bien entre menos 2
pero no siempre mi entrada tiene que ser
james puede ser no sé a y decir g
inversa de am es lo mismo que menos 1 -
3 am / al menos 2 o lo podemos llamar
como sea déjame ser más claro con esto
voy
para ahora este color y puedo decir que
g
inversa de quién bueno esto es lo que
tenemos acá abajo es lo mismo que menos
1 - 3
james entre 10 menos dos pero también
podemos decir no sé se me ocurre tomarme
una variable arbitraria tan arbitraria
como decir esto la función inversa de
carita feliz la función inversa de
carita feliz esto es lo mismo que y
bueno me quedaría menos uno menos tres
caritas felices menos tres caritas
felices
eso suena un poco raro esto dividido
entre carita feliz carita feliz menos 2
o bueno si queremos llamar a nuestra
variable de entrada x entonces podríamos
decir que g inversa de x la función
inversa de x es lo mismo que menos 1 - 3
/ x menos 2 y así ya habríamos acabado
ya veamos aquí la función inversa que
depende de x ahora quiere remarcar lo
siguiente a lo mejor estás diciendo que
esto es un poco confuso porque ahora le
estamos llamando a nuestro valor de
entrada x cuando realmente lo asocia
vamos con james cuando hablábamos de
rango y eso es cierto pero debes
recordar que estas variables son
solamente etiquetas etiquetas que le
ponemos a las cosas para poderla seguir
pero simplemente son lo que le llamamos
entradas entonces podemos llamar a esta
función inversa la función inversa de g
que dependen de bueno carita feliz oye o
equis o bsd o como quieras llamarle a la
entrada entonces con nos pidieron que
inversa en términos de x vamos a definir
a la entrada como x y eso quiere decir
que esta será la expresión que nos va a
llevar de regreso una última cosa
manera en que podéis hacer esto ya que
si piensas en todo lo que acaba de pasar
es que si decimos en este momento que
esta es la función
james igual a la función inversa de g
que depende de x bueno pues si lo
observas así esencialmente lo que
hiciste fue cambiar las variables
cambiamos la variable x por james y
viceversa entonces otra manera de hacer
esto es empezar donde empezamos justo
aquí y en este momento cambiar las
variables cambiar la variable x por
james y la variable x x que
esencialmente es lo mismo que yo hice en
el último paso y luego después de haber
hecho ese intercambio resuelve el par
ayer despejar alguien al final llegaría
al mismo resultado y puedes decir que
bien es igual a la función inversa de g
que depende de x entonces te invito a
que lo intentes por cualquiera de los
dos caminos